caleb starts off this hour in Oregon
hi Caleb welcome to the Dave Ramsey show
thanks Dave five
my question is last thursday somebody
broke into our garage he's stole a bunch
of stuff and it turns out that it was
the previous tenant and the complex
didn't switch to locks my question is if
this happened to you or what what kind
of response do you think the complex
should have for this I mean we lost
thousands of dollars and stuff some has
been recovered but is in police evidence
and we can't get it back others like our
late grandfather's tools have not been
recovered Wow and how do you know that
the locks were not that this guy used a
key because so it's the maintenance
man's adult son that did it and they
used to least attend or the garage and
the manager told me they didn't switch
the locks manager told you yeah and did
you have insurance we do have renter's
insurance but I don't know how it works
because the stuff has been recovered but
the police is saying it could take you
know how the case is settled before we
can get anything back okay well you need
to talk to her do you talk to your
insurance company about filing a claim
for sure well I think I would sit down
with the apartment manager and ask them
how much of this they were planning to
cover since this is their fault you know
we bought like three hundred dollars in
security cameras since then and and our
deductibles 500 on the renter's
insurance so for sure you know we'll be
eight hundred dollars out of our pocket
yeah but I mean I think they ought to
start writing some checks this is just
straight-up negligence on their part I
think if you were to contact an attorney
the attorney would probably tell you you
have an incredible case for what for a
bunch of recovery and probably some
punitive I mean that's just absurd
yeah it was pretty pretty frustrating on
the last thing money pregnant wife needs
to stress over his sons comeback coming
into our place and taking stuff yeah
yeah so are the locks of the launcher
change now right all right other kings
now I'm gonna you know took a look that
we actually caught the guy on camera
stealing packages from someone else the
next night so been a lot of fun right so
the guys he's obviously in custody I
assume they haven't got him yet he's
been missing in action oh yeah they're
getting cuz he's dumber than Iraq okay
well yeah I think you sit down with the
apartment manager and and/or their
superior and just say look I don't
really want to sit down with an attorney
but if you guys don't start getting a
really generous over this really fast
I'm gonna have to see what my legal
rights are because this is absolutely
asinine
you are so liable that you really ought
to be just writing me checks to keep me
happy right now
and you know I thought about it but I
mean if I were on the other side of that
if I were the landlord I would have
already made you an offer because this
is their fault
I mean they screwed this up okay well
you know number one we got a maintenance
man with a with a son who's a criminal
and he and we didn't change the locks
and he's a criminal has the key now
these are known things they know this
kid they know that this is the scum kid
had a key and they're so stinking lazy
that they didn't bother to change the
locks
that's just incompetence now you can be
nicer than that but that's where this
stands so yeah I think the first thing I
always do is I always confront the
person that you're dealing with you know
and just say listen let's try to work
this out because you're just obviously
very liable as you can imagine we are
really really really angry about this
but on top of that we're out a bunch of
money and it's all your fault and so you
guys need to you need to cut you need to
make us whole right here and so I'm
expecting you to cut me a check today
for $5,000 to cover my trouble and my
stuff that's gone and if you guys don't
want to be if you guys don't want to
begin
discussion about that right now then
that's going to force me to seek legal
counsel and I don't really want to do
that but I'm very angry I'm that this is
ridiculous
and you know I'm not going to yell at
you or cuss at you you're just the
manager but this is this is not okay and
it's not going to go away without
costing you some money because you're
liable on this and then just see what
they say if they offer you a couple
grand take it and move on and go on your
way because that's probably about all
you're gonna get after you fight about
this but I I would you know if I were
the landlord I wouldn't give you ten
grand okay but I would take care of your
stuff that got stolen and I'd make sure
that you know it that the locks are
changed and the cameras are done because
it's my fault you know and sometimes we
do stuff that's our fault we don't mean
for it to be but some people work for us
aren't competent sometimes it's just
your fault when that happens and you
have to take care of it so yeah I would
I would be pretty aggressive about it
I'm not gonna be mean to somebody not
yelling and cussing and stomping my foot
and don't even have to be unkind but you
do need to be very very very direct and
and if they don't react to that and they
say no we're not liable say well I guess
we'll have to find out and I would
contact an attorney for some legal
advice at that point